il lui a donné des coups sur la tête et
il a étranglé
la vie était en sous-vêtements et
nuisette
Maillan aurait ensuite forcer Bello à
transporter le cadavre toujours selon
Lopez Valérie n'étant pas morte maillon
aurait donc décidé
d'agiray la fille à main nue dans la
forêt
[Musique]
nous sommes au beau milieu du mois
d'août 1991
ATA ont les Vosges au bord de la Moselle
aux abords de ce petit village
tranquille de l'Est de la France
se trouve la forêt domaniale on est dans
les Vosges pas très loin d'Épinal dans
une forêt où le mois d'août et puis
l'argent d'arme qui est en train de se
balader dans cette forêt et son chien
s'arrête et va voir un petit peu dans la
forêt il voit son chien qui est qui est
attiré qui a un comportement un peu
bizarre
le gendarme le rappelle le faire venir
vers lui il s'approche il voit des
mouches des dizaines de mouches ils
s'avancent ils se demandent ce que c'est
si c'est pas un mannequin et puis il se
rend compte que c'est pas mannequin mais
c'est un cadavre le gendarme découvre le
corps d'une jeune femme totalement nue
et il n'y a plus rien à faire à première
vue elle est morte
ce gendarme voit ce qu'il y a d'oeuvre
et donc il va immédiatement aller voir
ses collègues pour pour les alerter le
militaire ne s'en doute pas encore mais
ce n'est que le début d'un feuilleton
judiciaire qui va durer près de 20 ans
la brigade de la gendarmerie de
Thaon-les-Vosges arrivera rapidement sur
les lieux du crime
les gendarmes à ce moment-là ils ont une
volonté d'être parfait ils essaient au
maximum de relever tous les indices
possibles et imaginables on sent que il
y a vraiment une volonté de mettre les
moyens en arrivant les gendarmes
relèvent un premier élément troublant
des traces de pneus tant en amont qu'en
aval du cadavre c'est pas une forêt où
les voitures s'aventurent souvent c'est
pas très facile d'accès etc
on pense que le corps a été déplacé le
meurtre a eu lieu ailleurs et a été posé
là par la suite car il y a pas de sang
autour il y a pas de traces de lutte
juste ces traces de pneus d'une voiture
qui recule et qui repart dans l'autre
sens les gens d'armes examinent alors la
jeune femme elle-même
âgée d'environ 20 ans et
les enquêteurs vont conclure à quelques
ecchymoses sur le corps et alors quelque
chose d'un peu plus étonnant des tout
petits impacts sur la peau sur les bras
sur les jambes des plaies superficiels
dont l'origine paraît bien mystérieuse
pour le moment
en revanche les enquêteurs ont déjà leur
petite idée sur les causes du décès de
la jeune femme la femme a torchon à
carreaux serré fort autour du cou donc
apparemment ce sont les premières
constatations les mortes comme ça
étouffée étrangler ce simple torchon
serait donc l'arme du crime reste à
trouver un mobile et déjà les enquêteurs
écartent une première piste tous ces
bijoux sur elle donc apparemment pas un
crime crapuleux les indices sont maigres
d'autant que rien ne permet d'identifier
la victime pour le moment
aucun vêtement aucun papier ne sont
retrouvés dans la forêt malgré d’intense
recherche
toutefois les enquêteurs remarquent un
petit détail un tatouage sur le lobe de
l'oreille un petit scorpion pour aider
les gendarmes dans l'or enquête un
médecin légiste et dépêché sur place et
un premier examen du cadavre apporte une
information précieuse le médecin légiste
constate donne un des premières
indications sur ce qu'ils appellent à
l'époque la rigidité cadavérique d'après
son expertise médico légale et d'après
son examen immédiat il s'agissait d'une
mort récente à savoir dans la nuit de
dimanche à lundi ou dans la matinée de
lundi 8h après la découverte du cadavre
les enquêteurs doivent se rendre à
l'évidence l'affaire s'annonce
particulièrement difficile le premier
soir je pense que les gendarmes ils ont
un Cornon identifié ils sentent que ça
va pas forcément être facile je pense
qu'ils ont conscience qu'une une grosse
voir une seule affaire leur tombe dessus
13 août 1991 institut médico-légal de
Strasbourg
l'autopsie du corps anonyme de la jeune
femme commence avec minutie
l'autopsie elle constate quoi une
strangulation d'abord à maintenu et puis
aussi à l'aide du torchon qu'on retrouve
autour du cou des ecchymoses des coups
portés à mains nues le médecin
s'intéresse ensuite aux étranges plaies
situées un peu partout sur le corps
elle a reçu 49 pics sur le corps ils
n'ont pas pu l'attribuer à telle ou tel
objet en passant dire si c'était un
couteau si c'était un pic à barbecue
enfin c'était un objet pointu mais il y
a une notion de souffrance et de torture
qui est évidente à la lecture de du
rapport d'autopsie ensuite le médecin
légiste cherche à vérifier la piste de
l'agression sexuelle
quand on découvre un candiduité on
imagine qu'il y ait un viol pourtant
d'après des premières analyses il n'y a
pas eu de traces de viol
alors pourquoi a-t-on retrouvé la
victime nue qu'a-t-il bien pu lui
arriver
impossible de le savoir pour l'instant
les investigations toxicologiques et
biologiques n'apportent pas davantage de
renseignements
seule nouvelle information et elle est
de taille leur précise de la mort que
les résultats de l'analyse du contenu de
l'oeil permettent d'ajuster regarde
cette nouvelle analyse
la date de la mort était plutôt 48
heures avant à savoir dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche et non plus comme on
le pensait au départ dans la nuit du
dimanche au lundi ou dans la matinée du
lundi
en revanche à ce stade des enquêteurs ne
connaissent toujours pas l'identité de
la victime mais cela ne va pas tarder et
cela grâce à la presse
14 août 1991 deux jours après la
découverte du corps la nouvelle de la
macabre découverte fait la une de la
presse locale
aider la publication des premiers
articles les gendarmes vont recevoir un
coup de téléphone qui devrait faire
avancer l'enquête
on a une directrice de centre aéré dans
les environs d'Épinal qui se rapprochent
des gendarmes et qui dit voilà moi j'ai
une personne une salariale qui s'appelle
Valérie Bechtel qui ne s'est pas rendu
au travail lundi ni mardi c'est pas
habituel c'est très étonnant alors je
m'inquiète parce que j'ai vu qu'il y
avait un cadavre retrouvé les gendarmes
demandent alors à la directrice de venir
identifier le corps à la mort
d'identification certain c'est
effectivement ce tatouage de ce petit
scorpion derrière Laurel le corps qu'on
a retrouvé en forêt de temps les Vosges
c'est bien le corps de Valérie Bechtel
la directrice de
Valérie Bechtel à 20 ans et cet
animatrice de centre aéré évite encore
chez ses parents cette directrice elle
va leur dire
c'est un petit village près d'Épinal
elle raconte que les parents de Valérie
sont actuellement en vacances en Espagne
un moment particulièrement difficile à
temps à présent les enquêteurs annoncer
la terrible nouvelle aux parents de
Valérie beschel
c'est donc par téléphone que les
gendarmes leur annoncent le décès de
leur fille
le papa et la maman de Valérie était
effondrée mais vous savez on n'a pas
grand chose à dire quand vous avez en
face de vous des gens qui sont effondrés
par la douleur les parents de la victime
n'ont aucune idée de ce qui a pu arriver
à leur fille
mais une perquisition à leur domicile ou
habitait Valérie va donner aux
enquêteurs des premiers éléments de
réponse
14 août 1991 à peine arrivé devant le
pavillon de la famille Bechtel à
Chavelot les gendarmes remarquent
quelque chose d'anormal
ces enquêteurs ne s'aperçoivent que
l'armée du garage une petite vitre a été
cassée et ce carreau cassé laisse penser
aux enquêteurs qu'un rôdeur c'est
peut-être introduit dans la maison
l'homme aurait croisé Valérie et les
choses auraient dérapé
[Musique]
pour confirmer leur hypothèse les
gendarmes entre et aussitôt découvre
d'autres indices qui viennent confirmer
leur intuition lorsqu'il pénètre à
l'intérieur il relève des traces de
lutte et des traces de sang ils
prélèvent des tapis prélève les draps
tout l'ensemble des choses qui peuvent
prélever sur une scène de crime présumée
quoi
en fouillant le moindre rock ou de la
maison les gendarmes vont faire une
autre découverte de taille celle-là ils
vont retrouver une fourche à viande dans
la cuisine cette fourche à viande les a
forcément Inter
Pellé malheureusement constaté sur le
corps de la victime 49 plaies pontiforme
en examinant le salon les enquêteurs
découvrent alors grande surprise un
objet a disparu un objet un seul on se
rencontre que un magnétoscope a disparu
le magnétoscope qui est juste sous la
télé dans le salon donc on se dit a
priori peut-être c'est un cambriolage
qui aurait mal tourné et il n'en faut
pas plus aux enquêteurs pour échafauder
une hypothèse
Valérie était là au mauvais moment et on
l'a tué sur place et on a on aurait
transporté son corps pour aller la poser
dans cette forêt de la souche petit à
petit le scénario commence à prendre
forme seulement comme souvent dans les
affaires criminelles il faut toujours se
méfier des apparences
17 août 1991 tous les habitants de
Chavelot se sont réunis dans la petite
église du village pour assister aux
obsèques de Valérie
les gendarmes aussi sont là
habillés en civils ils vont se noyer
dans la foule
ils enquêteurs viennent souvent aux
obsèques c'est assez fréquent et puis il
peut arriver effectivement que les
enquêteurs veuillent comment se fondre
dans la dans la foule ils viennent à
l'enterrement presque comme des copains
pour essayer de d'entendre ce qui se dit
établir des contacts etc et rapidement
les gendarmes entendent parler d'un
certain Christophe Gilot les gendarmes
ont mené leur petit enquête et ont
appris que Monsieur Gilot était le petit
ami de Madame Bechtel
et très vite les enquêteurs découvrent
que le petit ami de la victime n'est pas
inconnu des services de police
monsieur Gillot avait un petit passé une
affaire de stupéfiants et bien entendu
il faut savoir que lorsque il y a une
enquête les enquêteurs systématiquement
se dirigent vers les personnes qui ont
un casier judiciaire il n'en faut pas
plus pour que Christophe Gillot soit
interpellé et placé en garde à vue c'est
un des premiers vers lequel en tout cas
les si ce n'est les soupçons au moins
les questions assistantes vont se
tourner c'est lui qui va être cuisiner
le premier et grâce à Christophe Gillot
les gendarmes vont pouvoir reconstituer
l'emploi du temps de la victime le soir
du drame monsieur Gillot et la dernière
personne à l'avoir vu avant le drame
c'était allé ensemble au restaurant je
crois de mémoire que c'était un
restaurant chinois
donc il y a des témoins qui les ont vu
les deux ça s'est bien passé il y a pas
eu de disputes ensuite ils sont allés
boire des verres dont deux différents
bars et Christophe Gillot a ramené
Valérie Bechet et lui parce que la
voiture de la galerie était garée chez
lui Christophe Gilot a proposé à Valérie
de passer à New yelec elle refuse elle
dit non c'est trop tôt je te connais pas
encore assez bien donc il n'insiste pas
selon les dires de Gilot Valérie serait
ensuite rentré chez elle
cependant les gendarmes s'interrogent
face aux avances de Christophe et au
refus de la jeune femme le suspect se
serait-il énervé
aurait-il perdu tout contrôle et comédie
réparable les enquêteurs pensent détenir
une piste mais malheureusement pas pour
longtemps car des témoins l'affirment
Valérie Bechtel a bien regagné sa maison
quand elle rentre chez elle les voisins
l'entendent mais la voix entrer dans la
maison et lui avoir allumé la lumière de
sa chambre et lui avoir les tendres et
puis par ailleurs Christophe Gillot il a
un alibi était moins long vu ailleurs
chez lui donc il y a aucun souci il est
relâché à la fin de son audition pour
les gendarmes c'est la douche froide
l'enquête repart à zéro en l'absence de
résultats le malaise s'installe
lentement dans la petite localité vos
hygiène l'enquêteur sentent la pression
et archi il faut qu'il donne des
résultats il y a toujours rien puisqu'on
n'a pas de suspect puisqu'on n'a pas de
piste la suspicion parfois même les
dénonciations
grossissent et créer un climat
évidemment parfaitement délétère un
homme va pourtant faire rebondir
l'enquête un jeune homme qui connaissait
très bien la victime
sans l'ombre d'une piste les gendarmes
décident de fouiller dans la vie de la
victime
ils veulent savoir qui était Valérie
Bechtel il multiplie donc les auditions
des proches des amis et de toutes les
connaissances de la jeune femme
je sais qui cherche à vérifier le passé
de Valérie avec qui elle a été en
relation qui est susceptible de lui en
vouloir
d'un côté la jeune femme justement très
ponctuelle très appréciée de ses
employeurs
mais il y a aussi la Valérie du soir si
on peut dire du week-end c'est pas une
délurés mais c'est une fille qui aime
bien profiter qui aime bien sortir qui
écoutent du rock qui boit qui fument un
peu de temps en temps des joints et on
va essayer justement de d'enquêter
là-dessus on se dit que c'est
certainement dans cette zone là qu'il
faut qu'il faut aller et juste non
Valérie beschtel fréquentait un petit
groupe d'amis amateurs de rock de drogue
et qui aimait faire la fête ces jeunes
gens en savent sans doute plus qu'ils
n'en disent sur la mort de la jeune
femme c'est ce que les gendarmes se
disent d'ailleurs l'un d'eux va leur
apporter une aide précieuse
c'est là que un jeune homme de 20 ans à
peine va de lui-même venir parler aux
enquêteurs va venir aider les enquêteurs
ils se transformer un peu en détective
le jeune homme en question c'est Raphaël
Maillan les enquêteurs le connaissent
bien c'est un ancien petit ami de
Valérie et ils l'ont déjà entendu
plusieurs fois
il se retrouve finalement comme une
sorte de porte d'entrée dans un tout
petit dans un tout petit milieu qu'on
cherche à mieux connaître à mieux
identifier à mieux comprendre à l'en
croire Raphaël maillon veut tout mettre
en oeuvre pour trouver le ou les
assassins quitte à trahir ses amis
c'est ainsi qu'il va confier des
informations très sensibles sur un homme
un certain Yann Bello
à l'époque Yann Bello et Raphaël Maillan
sont amis en fait il se connaissent
depuis qu'ils sont adolescents enfin
depuis qu'ils ont 13 14 ans j'ai des
soirées fin des fêtes ensemble comme des
adolescents leurs points communs aussi
c'est qu'ils avaient eu la même petite
amie donc Valérie beschel Rafael maillon
révèle alors aux enquêteurs que quelques
semaines plus tôt Yann Belo lui avait
confié vouloir voler le magnétoscope des
Bechtel
les enquêteurs décident alors d'entendre
celui qu'il considère comme le nouveau
suspect de l'affaire
[Musique]
23 septembre 1991 Yann Belo est placé en
gardais
ce jeune homme de 21 ans est surnommé la
grenouille à cause de son apparente
fragilité
tout petit timide il a un petit polo
avec un pull on dirait un étudiant
anglais enfin vraiment le gars chétif
pourtant les gendarmes ne vont pas
s'arrêter à ce physique de 1er de la
classe et d'entrée de jeu ils
interrogent le jeune homme sur le
magnétoscope des robes chez des bechtels
lorsqu'on vient lui dire l'histoire de
magnétoscope etc pas du tout non non je
ne vois pas ce que vous voulez dire je
ne sais rien je comprends pas
Ian Belloni en bloc il n'a rien à voir
avec le vol du magnétoscope ni avec le
meurtre de Valérie bêche tel
concernant son emploi du temps le soir
du drame le jeune homme affirme même
disposer d'un alibi
j'étais avec des amis en ami on est allé
en discothèque
et puis on est rentré vers trois heures
trois heures et demie du matin
je n'ai ni vu ni croiser Valérie Bechtel
dans la nuit du samedi soir
seulement les gendarmes vont vite se
rendre compte que Yann Bello leur a
menti
tout semble désormais accablé Yann Bello
le jeune homme semblait connaître le nom
de la victime avant tout le monde
il y aurait un trou dans son emploi du
temps entre deux heures et 5 heures du
matin la nuit du drame
[Musique]
a voulu dérober le magnétoscope chez
attendait pas les choses ont dégénéré ça
a mal tourné pourtant on vérifiant cette
hypothèse les gendarmes vont réaliser
qu'ils n'ont pas à faire à un mais à
deux suspects
[Musique]
24 septembre 1991 la garde à vue de Yann
Bellot est prolongée les gendarmes
l'interrogent sans relâche et l'homme va
finir par parler
ils vont le cuisiner et ils vont le
mettre une pression
assez phénoménal et à la grande surprise
des enquêteurs Yann Belo va accuser son
meilleur ami Rafael Maillan
celui-là même qu'il avait dénoncé au
gendarmes dira oui j'étais là ce soir là
oui j'ai cambriolé le magnétoscope mais
j'étais pas seul et c'est pas moi qui ai
Valérie Yann Bello va dire je suis allé
avec Raphaël Maillan dans la maison des
parents Bechtel
et puis voilà ce qui s'est passé
les gendarmes enregistrent la déposition
de vélo
et c'est une histoire incroyable que les
officiers vont découvrir
une histoire qui démarre trois mois plus
tôt
[Musique]
nous sommes au début de l'été 1991
Bello vient de trouver un nouvel emploi
de massicotier dans une papeterie mais
malgré ce travail il a bien du mal à
joindre les deux bouts
intérimaire son meilleur ami Raphaël
Maillan à lui aussi des difficultés pour
s'en sortir financièrement
tous les deux avaient besoin d'argent
tous les deux ont eu l'idée du vol de ce
magnétoscope Bélo et Maillan sont déjà
venus chez les bechtels ils savent que
leur maison est équipée d'un
magnétoscope un bien qui à l'époque
coûte une petite fortune
Belo raconte donc ce qui se serait passé
la nuit du drame c'est moi qui suis allé
chercher
Raphaël Maillan au domicile de sa soeur
à Épinal et il m'a ouvert la porte je
suis monté dans le logement nous avons
fumé un pétard et ensuite tous les deux
nous sommes partis vers Chavelot
enfin les mois nous avons décidé d'aller
cambrioler la maison Bechtel nous
pensions que la maison était inoccupée
et l'eau et Maillan sont persuadés que
ce samedi soir valérie béchetel est
resté chez son petit ami il pense donc
que la Voix est Libre le domicile de la
famille Bechtel est situé à 8 km à peine
de chez Raphaël Maillan en moins d'un
quart d'heure les deux hommes seraient
arrivés devant la maison et il n'aurait
tu aucune difficulté à entrer dans le
pavillon
on est passé comme on faisait tout le
temps quand on allait chez elle parlent
garage le petit hublot qui était cassé
on a ouvert la porte il monte du
sous-sol à l'étage on arrive dans le
couloir à droite se trouve le salon
salle à manger où se trouve le
magnétoscope à gauche se trouve la
cuisine ils ouvrent le réfrigérateur
pour avoir un peu de lumière à
l'intérieur de la maison chacun semble
avoir son rôle et ses Bello qui aurait
pu pour mission de voler l'objet tant
convoité pendant qu'il ne s'affairait à
débrancher le magnétoscope dans la
pénombre Rafael Maillan était chargé de
de ramasser tous les objets supposément
de valeur jusque là tout se serait bien
passé pour les deux cambrioleurs
amateurs mais selon Bello ce qui devait
être un simple vol sans effraction
aurait brusquement tourné au drame
curieusement Raphaël Maillan va aller
dans le couloir
jusqu'au fond
à droite il y a la chambre de Valérie
un cri féminin quand il montre les
escaliers ils vend des directions de la
chambre de Valérie et là il voit une
scène hallucinante Valérie en petite
tenue culotte t-shirt à genoux sur son
lit et Raphaël grand Raphaël devant elle
ils ont une altercation violente Valérie
les interpellent tous les deux en
réponse
une espèce d'énormes gifle et Raphaël
Maillan exhorte Yann Bello a quitter la
maison selon Yann Bello voici ce que
Rafael Maillan lui aurait dit à ce
moment-là il m'a dit casse-toi c'est pas
ton affaire c'est entre Valérie et moi
Yann Bello raconte alors aux enquêteurs
être parti
je m'en vais et prix de remords un petit
peu avant Épinal je reviens je fais
machine arrière
un quart d'heure plus tard il y a de
nouveau dans la maison des bechetels et
il trouve raphètent dans le garage je
voulais dire complètement hagard et il
lui dit Valérie a tombé dans les pommes
ils se rendent dans le salon in bello
continue son récit et voilà ce qu'il
raconte au gendarmes je suis tombé sur
le corps de Valérie Michel qui était
dans le salon allongé par terre
il affirme même que il est pas forcément
sûr à ce moment-là qu'elle est morte
Yann Bello poursuit sa déposition et
affirme que c'est lui qui aurait décidé
de se débarrasser du corps de Valérie
non moi j'ai pas voulu appeler les
policiers j'ai pas voulu sermonner
Raphaël ou quoi que ce soit il dit bon
bah écoute on peut pas rester comme ça
on va prendre le corps c'est sous
l'impulsion Diane on va prendre le corps
et on va aller le déposer plus loin en
forêt
maillon prend en prend Valérie par par
les épaules Yann Bellou par par les
jambes il la mettent dans la voiture il
y a une Diego conduire à feuille Maillan
et place du passager et il se rendent
dans cette forêt quelques kilomètres de
là en pleine nuit
il dira on laisse le corps là et on
repart et on se jure qu'on en parle plus
jamais en rentrant chez lui il y a une
Bello magnétoscope sous le bras il va
dissimuler dans sa chambre
il y a une Belleau raconte que le
lendemain sa mère l'aurait disputé car
il était rentré trop tard la veille puis
il aurait retrouvé Mayan et quelques
amis pour une sortie
et ils font comme ici dans la tête fort
de ce pacte c'est ainsi que Yann Bellot
termine sa déposition seulement les
gendarmes m'ont bien du mal à y croire
le jeune homme affirme alors pouvoir
prouver ses propos il indique aux
enquêteurs où se trouve le magnétoscope
des Bescherelles il l'aurait finalement
jeté dans une décharge conscient qu'il
s'agissait d'une pièce à conviction
monsieur Bello
crédible en ce sens qu'il a parlé du
Métroscope qui se trouvait dans une
décharge et lorsqu'ils enquêteurs se
sont rendus dans la décharge ils l'ont
retrouvé ce Métroscope selon la
déposition de Yann Bello tout semble
désigner Rafael Maillan comme le
meurtrier
reste au gendarmes à entendre celui qui
dans cette affaire fait désormais figure
de suspect numéro 1
24 septembre 1991 les gendarmes se
rendent à Épinal ils savent que Rafael
maillon travaille sur un chantier il lui
demande de les suivre pour l'auditionner
à nouveau sans lui préciser que son ami
Yenne Belo la formellement accusé
[Musique]
les gendarmes viennent le chercher sans
menottes sans rien et lui demande de
l'accompagner au poste les gendarmes
viennent me chercher son chantier donc
je pense qu'ils ont besoin de mon
témoignage donc il imagine pas une seule
seconde qu'il soit visé en qualité de
hauteur principal de cette affaire
arriver à la gendarmerie les enquêteurs
annoncent à Raphaël Maillan qui les
plaçait en garde à vue car son meilleur
ami Yann Belo la dénoncer
[Musique]
et là Raphaël tombe des nues il
hallucine totalement il se dit c'est pas
possible il a dit moi je conteste
formellement je n'étais pas dans cette
maison ce que dit Bello ce sont des
fariboles c'est complètement faux il va
dire au gendarme attendez c'est moi qui
vous a dirigé vers Bello vous pensez pas
que j'aurais fait ça si j'étais avec lui
ce triste samedi soir dans la maison
Mechtel le jeune intérimaire répète donc
aux officiers ce qu'il a déjà déclaré
plusieurs fois la dernière fois j'ai vu
Valérie il me semble que c'était le
samedi soir elle a été avec Christophe
Gillot je la rencontrer dans une galère
ma chambre c'est juste du bonjour et
voilà selon Rafael Maillan ils n'ont
fait que se croiser le jeune homme
précise ensuite au gendarmes la suite de
s’asseoir il disait que de toute façon
le soir des faits il était allé boire un
verre en ville qu'il était rentré chez
lui plus exactement chez sa sœur qu'il
avait passé la nuit que sa sœur n'était
pas là ce soir là qu'il n'avait
absolument aucune preuve de ce qu'il
était resté chez sa sœur qui n'était pas
sorti de cet appartement et que le
lendemain matin vers 9h
Ian Bello était venu le chercher comme
c'était prévu pour l'emmener à la
piscine en Alsace cette dernière partie
du récit est le seul point qui coïncide
avec ce que dit Yann Bello
pour savoir lequel des deux hommes dit
vrai les gendarmes vérifient alors
l'emploi du temps de Raphaël Maillan le
soir du crime
on interroge bien entendu les tenanciers
de ces établissements on n'a pas vu on
n'a pas vu Maillan dans ses
établissements toutes les investigations
visant à confirmer ou infirmer son
emploi du temps et bien ont tourné à sa
totale confusion aucun témoin ne peut
donc confirmer le déroulement de la
soirée les taux se resserrent autour de
Raphaël Maillan
les enquêteurs vont alors tenter de
confondre le suspect et il lui pose une
question a priori anodine un gendarme
présente un maillon une fourche à viande
et dites à Mayotte ça sert à quoi cet
instrument quand on monte le petit
camion j'ai gendarmes qui qui l'a dans
une main et qui explique un petit peu la
main comme ça et puis il me dit à quoi à
quoi ça pourrait servir je vois bien que
c'est un picavience et je vois bien ce
qui sous-entend alors je dis ce qu'ils
vont entendre que ça peut servir à
piquer quelqu'un
les enquêteurs se regardent ils se
disent non mais c'est pas possible la
saillie on tient notre bonhomme le tueur
de Valérie bestel c'est bien lui c'est
Rafael Maillan comment il peut répondre
ça pour les enquêteurs l'affaire semble
presque bouclée reste à établir les
circonstances exactes du crime s'agit-il
réellement d'un cambriolage qui aurait
mal tourné
l'incubation de Yann Bellot et Raphaël
Magnan pour homicide volontaire le
mobile du crime reste flou les deux les
deux jeune homme pardon seront
confrontés demain matin dans le bureau
du juge d'instruction à Épinal après 48
heures de garde à vue une confrontation
est organisée entre les deux inculpés
ceux qui quelques heures plus tôt se
définissaient encore comme meilleures
amies
alors que les deux hommes sont conduits
au Palais de Justice d'Épinal plusieurs
journalistes sont présents parmi eux il
y a Alain DUSARD lorsque nous faisons
donc la sortie du fourgon de Rafael
Maillan d'un côté et de Yann Bello de
l'autre il y a une belle au sort avec la
tête baissée et Rafael Maillan lui sort
la tête du fourgon écrit je n'ai rien
fait Bello et Maillan arrivent menotté
devant le juge d'instruction la
confrontation est extrêmement tendue et
Madame le jeu instruction était très
perplexe la juge et les enquêteurs
savent que cette confrontation peut leur
permettre de découvrir lequel des deux
hommes à menti pour cela ils vont user
d'un stratagème
on va enlever les menottes du Grand
vaillant et du frêle Bello et là si
Mayan est innocent qu'il a été accusé à
tort par Bello il va lui sauter dessus
et c'est humain et c'est logique je
crois que on ne peut absolument pas
concevoir
que qu'un homme normalement constitué
qui est accusé à tort par son meilleur
ami par son frère de cœur on ne peut pas
concevoir que il ne va pas réagir on va
se passer quelque chose il doit se
passer quelque chose
[Musique]
Bello étant votre ami pourquoi dire
votre ami qui vous aime bien qui vous
veut du bien pourquoi diable
lancerait-il contre vous les accusations
d'une gravité telle que celle que nous
avons dans ce dossier un mois et demi
après la mort de Valérie Bechtel
ces deux jeunes hommes sont inculpés du
meurtre de la jeune femme
le juge d'instruction va les inculper et
décide dans la foulée de les placer tous
les deux en détention le 29 septembre
1991 Raphaël Maillan et Yann Bello sont
donc placés en détention provisoire à la
maison d'arrêt d'Épinal monsieur
catastrophe en prison mais je suis pas
très inquiet sur sur la suite parce que
je me dis que mon essence m'a été vite
reconnue toute la famille de Raphaël
Maillan soutient alors le jeune homme a
commencé par Geneviève Maillan sa mère
mais je suis contente de l'avoir vu je
maintiens toujours qu'il est innocent
désormais une simple question se pose
qui a tué Valérie Bechtel Yann Bello
Raphaël Maillan
ou peut-être les deux
[Musique]
alors que Raphaël Maillan Yann Belo sont
en détention provisoire l'instruction
suit son cours les reconstitutions des
faits n'ont rien donné alors les espoirs
des enquêteurs reposent maintenant sur
les conclusions des experts
scientifiques leur but définir le rôle
exact de chacun dans cette histoire
les cheveux que l'on retrouve dans la
voiture de bello
les traces de sang qui sont les poignées
de porte partout partout aucune
empreinte digitale n'est retrouvée et à
l'époque l'ADN n'existe pas pourtant
Rafael Maillan on est persuadé la
science l'innocentrale un jour il avait
l'espoir que des expertises
à la suite de prélèvements effectués
démonterait qu'il était totalement
étranger à cette affaire et il a vécu
dans cet espoir pendant de longs moments
après quelques semaines les résultats
des analyses de la scène de crime
tombent on ne retrouve pas trace aucune
preuve à l'achat à charge contre rafale
Maillan devant ce manque d'éléments à
charge maillon continue de se battre son
avocat multiplie les demandes de mise en
liberté de son client mais elles sont
toutes refusées
mais nécessite de calmer son innocence
d'écrire au magistrats 17 plus quoi
faire pour prouver son innocence alors
ça passe par une grève de la fin il va
demander à être confronté à un détecteur
de mensonge Raphaël Maillan est inculpé
vous le savez dans le crime de Valérie
bechel illame son innocence il a entamé
une grève de la faim il a perdu 6 kg ça
peut paraître la plus curieuse si vous
voulez ou un peu loufoque comme attitude
mais c'est celle d'un garçon qui voulait
à toute force démontrer son innocent
l'affaire semble piétiner mais deux ans
après le meurtre de Valérie Bechtel elle
va prendre un nouveau virage
haute 1993 plus de deux ans après le
meurtre de Valérie beschtel la juge
d'instruction prend une décision
radicale
pour elle les faits sont évidents
Ian Bellot lui a dit la vérité le
coupable c'est Rafael Maillan Bello
n'est que complice conséquent immédiate
il est remis en liberté
cette instruction va déboucher au bout
de deux années d'un carcération sur une
un abandon des charges concernant
Yann Bello du chef de meurtre les
poursuites sont requalifiées il est
juste poursuivi pour recel de cadavres
et l'avoir transporté in bello libéré
c'est un coup dur pour Raphaël Maillan
la requalification des faits pour Yann
Bello est nouveau une catastrophe pour
moi parce que du coup je deviens le seul
coupable et je deviens le coupable idéal
comme l'institution judiciaire ne peut
pas se permettre de laisser un crime
impuni on se dit que nécessairement
on tient l'un des deux etc et qu'on peut
pas laisser s'échapper alors on fait un
choix et l'institution judiciaire un
moment donné elle choisit une version à
ce moment-là de l'enquête on peut on
peut considérer que effectivement ce
sont principalement les déclarations de
de Yann Bello qui engendre qui entraîne
la culpation de Rafael Maillan Raphaël
Maillan toutefois ne perd pas tout
espoir sans preuve matérielle face à
Yann Belo ce sera parole contre parole
mais c'est sans compter sur l'apparition
d'un nouveau personnage
nous sommes le 22 septembre 1993 et un
nouveau témoin demande à être entendu
par les enquêteurs
[Musique]
de Monsieur le Procureur un témoin
un témoin miracle il s'agit d'un certain
Lopez et il n'est autre que le CO détenu
de Rafael Maillan
un détenu qui prétend avoir été en
cellule ou avoir été en cours de gym à
la maison d'arrêt avec Raphaël Maillan
dit que Rafael Maillan lui aurait fait
des aveux heureux reconnu être l'auteur
du bas c'est révélations sont d'autant
plus prises au sérieux que ce Lopez est
un homme que les enquêteurs connaissent
bien et qui leur semble plutôt crédible
Lopez d'ailleurs avait déjà balancé si
je puis ainsi m'exprimer un autre côté
tenues dans une affaire criminelle à
Toulon et ce que Lopez avait dit au juge
de Toulon c'est avéré exact donc on a pu
supposer que les déclarations de Lopez
au juge d'Épinal était également exact
et voici ce que raconte Lopez au sujet
des révélations que Rafael Maillan lui a
fait
il lui a donné des coups sur la tête et
il a étranglé
la vie était en sous-vêtements et
nuisette
Maillan aurait ensuite forcer Bello à
transporter le cadavre toujours selon
Lopez Valérie n'étant pas morte Maillan
aurait donc décidé d'agir maillon achevé
la fille à main nue dans la forêt
ensuite le CO des tenues raconte que
Bello aurait transporté le magnétoscope
chez les bechtels mais les enquêteurs
sont circonspects car plusieurs
incohérences émaillent le témoignage de
Lopez
nu et non pas habillé et il dit que
c'est lui qui a pris l'initiative
d'arriver dans la forêt que Mayan ne va
pas du tout forcer béluga de ce corps
qui bougerait encore une fois dans le
fossé qu'on aurait dû achever et puis
surtout Bego il a jamais ramené
Métroscope chez les beinstein puisqu'il
y a des bolets dans la décharge là où
les enquêteurs vont retrouver sur cette
indication après vérification Raphaël
Maillan et ce nouveau témoin ont bien
été incarcérés dans la même prison mais
rien ne prouve qu'ils ont été en contact
Mayan a protesti violemment disant que
Lopez est à nafabulateur un esprit
faible ça paraît vraiment très doute la
qualité du témoin pas extraordinaire et
en plus il aurait reçu des confessions
c'est quand même assez étrange puisque
Mayan n'a jamais dit à qui que ce soit
d'autre je vois pas comment il aurait pu
choisir un peu détenu pour lui expliquer
ça en fait qui ne connaissait pas ça me
paraît très très bizarre
face aux nombreux doutes concernant le
témoignage de Lopez et faute d'éléments
matériels à charge Rafael maillon est
remis en liberté le 31 décembre 1993
après 27 mois de détention dont le doute
faute de véritable preuve matérielles de
mobiles Raphaël Maillan et est libéré en
demeurant mis en examen pour meurtre
c'est l'explosion de joie quoi voilà
j'ai presque tout laissé j'ai rien pris
je n'ai pas souvent je sors voilà ça a
été
un grand moment pour moi et ma famille
Raphaël maillon a pour interdiction de
retourner dans les Vosges ou de prendre
contact avec vélo
seulement le jeune homme est pourtant
loin d'avoir échappé aux griffes des
enquêteurs qui eux pensent que le jeune
homme avait peut-être une raison très
personnelle de vouloir tuer Valérie
Bechtel
plus de deux ans et demi après la mort
de Valérie les gendarmes interrogent à
nouveau les proches de la jeune femme et
découvre une information inédite
était toujours amoureux de Valérie
bechetel ceci étant dit plusieurs
témoignages on atteste rafale maillon de
cachait pas ses intentions de renouer
avec Valérie Bescher fort de ces
nouvelles informations les enquêteurs
imaginent alors un nouveau scénario prix
de jalousie lorsqu'il aurait aperçu de
la grippe quelques heures avant son
décès au bras d'un nouveau petit ami il
serait senti humilié et puis cette
colère froide serait ressortie quelques
heures plus tard à travers des coups
cette triste nuit de samedi à dimanche
ou malheureusement Valérie Wechel se
trouve dans sa chambre dans son lit
est-ce que nous ne sommes pas finalement
dans le cadre d'un crime passionnel les
enquêteurs n'ont aucune preuve pour
accréditer cette thèse et pourtant c'est
avec cette version des faits corroboré
par Yann Bello que les deux jeunes gens
vont être renvoyés devant la cour
d'assises
de leur côté les avocats de Maillan
tente de contre-attaquer et fondent tous
leurs espoirs sur les progrès de la
police scientifique depuis le crime la
science a progressé et on peut
maintenant sur ce torchon de cuisine
faire des investigations scientifiques
qu'on ne pouvait pas faire il y a
quelques années souvenez-vous un torchon
de cuisine avait été retrouvé nous et
autour du cou de Valérie beechtel
retrouvez un autre ADN que celui de
Rafael Maillan sur le linge permettrait
de l'innocenter malheureusement la cour
d'assise a dit non nous estimons que
nous en savons suffisamment ce dossier
est complet l'instruction insuffisamment
durée le crimes ancien il faut
maintenant juger sur le fond
le 12 mars 1990 sept après 4 ans et demi
d'instruction le procès pour le meurtre
de Valérie Bechtel s'ouvre à Épinal
Yann Belo est accusé de vol en réunion
de non-assistance à personne en danger
et de recettes de cadavre il risque 5
années de prison
Rafael Maillan quant à lui est accusé de
meurtre il risque 20 ans
d'emprisonnement une peine d'autant plus
lourde que l'homme a refait sa vie et
qu'il est père de deux jeunes enfants
j'avais dit à Mayan avant le procès je
lui ai dit Mayen c'est le procès de
l'intime conviction vous serez ou bien
si Dieu le veut vous serez acquitter ou
bien vous aurez 20 ans la famille de
Valérie se dirige vers la salle
d'audience principale et n'a qu'une
question en tête Rafael Maillan a-t-il
pu tuer leur fille
on a l'impression d'une ambiance
extrêmement lourde tout le monde était
passionné par ce procès et tout le monde
se sentait impliqué on sent que cette
affaire à cliver comme ça un peu les
amis les familles et on a été un moment
donné prier de choisir son camp le
procès n'est pas encore commencé que
déjà un élément influence les jurés
étant accusé de meurtre Rafael Maillan
ne bénéficie pas du même traitement que
Yann Bello
Bayan devait la veille du procès se
constitue prisonnier et il était dans le
box encadré par deux gendarmes quand
j'arrive aux assises je m'aperçois que
bah il y a que moi qui a le menottes il
y a une belle eau est là et que lui n'a
pas les menottes donc au niveau de
l'équité pour les jurés déjà je
m'aperçois qu'elle est pas là
il y avait une profonde inégalité et de
ce fait la parole de bello qui est en
liberté devenait convaincante et forte
alors que la parole de Mayan qui était
en prison au moment du procès devenait
évidemment comment dirais-je faible et
très peu audible dès le premier jour du
procès les parties adverses le ton est
vif la passion monte mais face aux
accusations l'attitude de maillon
déroute les jurés le jeune homme ne
réagit pas ou à peine
Maillan à aucun moment ne s'insurge
Maillan a le regard qui fuit à aucun
moment maillant lorsqu'il dit je n'ai
rien fait ne se tourne vers celui qui
l'accuse il est là il dit rien il attend
encore une fois il croit que la justice
va faire son chemin qu'on va le
reconnaître innocent les avocats de la
partie civile et de Yann Belo entrevoit
la faille et en profite pour charger
Maillan
au fur et à mesure des interrogatoires
je me suis aperçu que c'était moi
considère et non il y a une belle Bello
à la fin des débats le public il est
juré se sont fait leur opinion sur les
deux hommes
Rafael Maillan semble aussi imposant que
hautain tandis que Bello apparaît calme
et sincère
après seulement trois jours de débat le
jury se retire pour délibérer
les assises c'est toujours la roue russe
on n'a pas de on n'a pas de preuve
matérielle on n'a pas de véritable
mobiles convaincants c'est un peu parole
contre parole c'est un peu un procès
basé sur des impressions sur du feeling
sur de la subjectivité
14 mars 1997 la salle d'audience est
surchauffée Yann Bello et Raphaël
Maillan attendre le verdict mais ce
dernier n'a plus beaucoup d'illusions
même si au fond de moi j'ai toujours de
l'espoir j'y crois plus parce que j'ai
vu comment c'est comment sont présentés
les débats il n'aura fallu que trois
heures de délibération au 9 jurés pour
établir le jugement il est 22h lorsque
le verdict tombe
c'est neuf personnes vont dire oui
effectivement
dès l'Audi la vérité oui effectivement
maillon et coupable monsieur maillot à
17 ans de réclusion criminel
et Monsieur Bello n'a pris que deux ans
à l'annonce du verdict Raphaël maillon
s'effondre
c'est une catastrophe pour moi pour ma
famille pour mes enfants pour si je
m'étais reconstruit entre temps pour mes
parents pour voilà c'est catastrophique
c'est catastrophique il est complètement
hébété il n'y croit pas se repli sur
lui-même en larmes même l'avocat de la
famille Bechtel et surpris de la
sévérité du jugement
Raphaël Maillan est condamné à deux ans
de plus que la peine requise par
l'avocat général on a tous eu le
sentiment je me rappelle au moment des
verdict que Belo s'en sortait bien et
maillon payait ses silences
Raphaël Maillan est incarcéré au centre
de détention d'Écrouves en
Meurthe-et-Moselle
l'appel en matière de crimes n'existant
pas encore la défense pour vous en
cassation il sera rejeté le 21 janvier
1998 l'homme reste incarcéré et cette
fois pour de bon
10 années ont passé grâce au jeu de
remise de peine Raphaël Maillan est
libéré nous sommes le 23 février 2004 et
chose incroyable l'homme a convié la
télévision
il faut dire qu'à peine sortie Rafael
maillon n'a qu'une obsession crier son
innocence mon nom de ma libération
conditionnelle mon sentiment c'est de
tourner une page c'est la version mais
c'est aussi dans l'ouvrir une nouvelle
celle de me battre qui ressort il a deux
cesses son premier projet sa première
obsession c'est de demander la révision
de son procès Raphaël Maillan veut
pouvoir marcher la tête haute il va se
battre aux côtés de sa nouvelle avocate
pour que son procès puisse être révisé
Raphaël Maillan et son avocate mis sur
les progrès de la science
[Musique]
en espérant que avec une reouverture de
si on pourrait faire analyser le torchon
et faire des recherches ADN et dit il
faut qu'on regarde dans les scellés
maintenant on a l'ADN on peut prouver
des choses regarder les gars
malheureusement Rafael Maillan apprend
que les scellés chose incroyables ont
été détruits quelques mois plus tôt
suite à une erreur matérielle
il s'avérait que c'est scellés ont été
détruits le 12 novembre 2003 à la même
date que ce jugement de libération
conditionnelle
c'est une coïncidence pour le moins
étrange pour autant Rafael Maillan ne
baisse pas les bras son avocate va alors
mettre en avant un autre élément
contradictoire la datation de la mort de
Valérie Bescherelle ils vont obtenir le
témoignage de du légiste de l'époque qui
admet que il pourrait y avoir une
interprétation sur la date de la mort
d'après de nouvelles études
médico-légales c'est dans la nuit de
dimanche à lundi 12 août 1991 que ce
serait produit le meurtre et non le
samedi comme le médecin légiste l'avait
affirmé à l'époque or Raphaël Maillan a
un alibi pour ce soir-là il dînait avec
sa sœur mais la Cour d'appel n'est pas
convaincue
le deuxième procès
Henri par
d'un élément suffisamment nouveau son
combat se termine donc en 2006 par un
double échec si il est libre Raphaël
Maillan reste officiellement un
meurtrier cependant un événement survenu
récemment pourrait bien relancer cette
affaire
[Musique]
18 juillet 2011 20 ans après la mort de
Valérie Bechtel Yann Bellot est
soupçonné d'avoir tué sa femme
et cela dans des circonstances
étrangement similaires au meurtre de
Valérie beschel Yann
La Rochelle il s'est marié avec une
jeune fille beaucoup plus jeune que lui
et puis ce couple se sépare avec un
enfant au milieu c'est un divorce
terrible lui il veut garder son enfant
un enfant qu'il aime
elle part il en peut plus il essaie de
la convaincre reste c'est une dispute ça
tourne mal la frappe et il finit par
l'étrangler Yann Bello se fera arrêter
quelques heures plus tard il sera mis en
garde à vue et rapidement il avouera il
dira oui j'ai pété les plombs je l'ai
tué Yann Bello a avoué son geste sans
pouvoir l'expliquer il évoque un crime
passionnel tant qu'il n'est pas jugé il
reste présumé innocent mais un détail
dans ce crime va particulièrement
attirer l'attention des enquêteurs les
choses incroyable on découvrira
qu'autour de son cou et elle a une
serviette elle a été étranglée par une
serviette
et là tout de suite on plonge 20 ans en
arrière on se dit non mais c'est pas
possible c'est comme avec Valérie il y a
une symétrie sur la mort par
strangulation il y a une symétrie sur la
souffrance qu'après c'est des la mort
donc à 20 ans on intervalle quasiment
jour pour jour les points communs sont
troublants et Sylvie noahkovic avocate
de Raphaël Maillan décide d'appeler son
client
mon premier sentiment c'est de dire rien
n'était fait avant il faut de nouveau
une nouvelle victime pour que pour qu'on
reparle le moins Raphaël Maillan on est
persuadé la tragique mort de la femme de
Yann Bello pourrait lui permettre de
prouver son innocence en octobre 2011 il
dépose donc une troisième demande de
révision la défense de Rafael maillon va
demander
que le dossier de Valérie bestel soit
relu à la lumière de la violence et de
la portée des faits de La Rochelle mais
pour l'ancien avocat de Yann Bello il
n'y a pas lieu de ré-ouvrir l'affaire
Bechtel
viennent Bello je l'ai toujours vu
reconnaître ce qu'il avait fait
et je pense très honnêtement que s'il
avait participé d'une quelconque façon
je dis bien d'une quelconque façon au
crime au crime proprement dit de Valérie
Wechel
il leur dit
chose rare ici le 23 janvier 2012 la
commission de révision des condamnations
pénales a ordonné un supplément
d'information pour Raphaël Mayence est
un pas de plus vers une révision et
peut-être même un nouveau procès et du
coup pour lui l'espoir d'être innocenté
en attendant pour la justice française
Rafael maillon reste le seul coupable du
meurtre de Valérie Bechtel